yes I feel like this trailer has changed
the tone of the anthem of the Star Wars
curtain cave it is now a new trailer for
Star I love this thing I just do this we
have a new trailer for Star Wars rogue
one the Star Wars rogue one the trailer
campaign continues to do everything well
it continues to do it right because as
we're watching it there are no real plot
reveals in this trailer just like the
last trailer we know the Star Wars rogue
one has to do with the rebel spies who
got the Death Star plans and what this
trailer does is it shows us what I was
hoping that director would show us which
is scope it's the scope of the Death
Star and the Empire we see the scope
that does all right first of all if you
find out that your evil Galactic
government has built a spherical shaped
death machine about the size of a small
moon and you see that [ __ ] yeah you're
on a bull's eye move now my move I mean
flight you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] we suspected but they just it
looked so cool when I saw that there's a
great way of showing the size the Death
Star is eclipsing the Sun do not know
what this dude's gonna do that dude just
looks bad he just looks mean it shows
this it shows him folks are dead they've
seen where that Star Destroyer is just
chilling really made me think of the
empire on a much more personal level I
mean that shot of the Empire's
proverbial heel on the neck of this
planet I hope now rogue one takes place
on this one planet for the entirety of
it I start us out on a space base
somewhere sure but I want a really
personal look on how the Empire
detrimental e makes a world worse
because of its presence there
economically personally I just want to
see that I want to see why this Empire
totally needs to be stopped I just I
love that shot it just really
Illustrated everything I wanted it to
illustrate for me
we got blind badass Donnie Yen over here
otherwise known as dude he's gonna kick
a lot of Imperial [ __ ] ass yeah I got
a lot of [ __ ] for my first rogue one
trailer where I called him Morgan from
The Walking Dead because he fought with
a stick and Morgan from The Walking Dead
fights with a stick and people were like
look I believe he's black I was just a
joke about fighting with this dick so it
was he's a Jedi - I think I saw
somewhere on Twitter that that it was
revealed that he was a Jedi I think I
totally stay out of the rumor mill I
don't know what the rumors are about
these movies I like going into my Star
Wars
he's completely fresh but I think I
heard he's a Jedi and I hope he's a Jedi
because if they have a Jedi in this
movie you know that dudes gonna fight
Darth Vader if that's true Vader will
show us what is probably going to be the
greatest Vader lightsaber fight in
history then you see jyn erso is their
name jyn erso she's totally a spy I'm
just saying in the last trailer it shows
her in a TIE fighter outfit when Forest
Whitaker's like you because then it
shows her walking towards a TIE fighter
with no fear whatsoever is clearly what
she's trying to do is go towards that
TIE fighter that could blow her away
since she's not particularly afraid of
it I have to assume it's not going to
blow her away granted I'm sure rebels
have control of the TIE fighter I'm just
saying for some odd reason in this
campaign there are little things that
make you think they're trying to get you
to think she is a spy I don't know why
and I just find it curious cherry on top
you think the trailers over and they're
like all right you all know that Darth
Vader is in this movie we've told you
he's in this movie we told you he's a
badass in this movie so here here's his
dome dome element his dome head he's
looking at plans of some sort he's
probably doing the most boring tasks
average his stupid paper working she's
like [ __ ] eight tax season
stupid imperial taxes and i think i love
in this trailer is what you kind of saw
in the last rogue one trailer and you
see more of in this trailer is just to
change up in style among directors I
mean when we knew the Star Wars movies
in the Star Wars universe we're going to
have different directors we knew the
styles would just be different it's just
great to see that the force awakens look
different than the prequels rogue one
looks different to the force awakens
just different rogue one looks like a
war action drama that takes place in a
galaxy far far away these are not
negatives as far as I'm concerned is
pretty easily present the end I'm just
I'm pumped for this movie because of how
the trailers are going this trailer
carries on the tradition of what the
force awakens trailer gave us which is
hey there's not a lot of plot points in
here doesn't matter that's what makes it
good you see tone scope couple of
characters couple of villains and Star
Wars ish things I guess that's the leg
up the Star Wars has among other
franchises out there you don't have to
show much man you should it's Star Wars
for God's sake because they're any other
franchise that makes me dress up in a
curtain that I had as a child and where
does the cable I'm talking about it no
there is not and to see this chapter
that will stitch in with the opening
crawl of the original Star Wars movie I
want to see when we when I watch that
original Star Wars movie again I don't
I just call it Star Wars because I'm
stubborn like that but when I see that
opening crawl I want to remember
everything that everybody in rogue one
did is like oh my god those who gave
their lives right guys so the new Star
Wars rogue one trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more